[Music]
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
this session today we're going to be
talking about machine learning options
for mobile developers I'm Laurence
Moroney I'm an AI advocate at Google and
I'm you right from the firebase
developer relations team so we get a lot
of feedback from developers and
particularly mobile developers about
there are just so many options when it
comes to machine learning even at Google
we've got all of these options you've
probably seen lots of this today you
walk around the expo hall you see cloud
has a number of offerings
we've got firebase MLK it we've got
tensorflow android has some offerings
and we get a lot of feedback about how
confusing that is and somebody who's a
mobile developer who just really wants
to take advantage of machine learning
build that into their mobile
applications they need a road map they
need to figure out what do they do which
offering do they use which product do
they use so what we're here today to
talk about so hopefully to try and clear
that up a little bit hopefully help you
understand what the choices are when you
would make particular choices so the
question of course is okay well where do
I start
what can machine land what can machine
learning um sometimes to a machine
language but that's a different thing
what can machine learning do for me and
really why should I care so always like
to level set before I go into some of
the offerings of machine learning and
just talk a little bit about what
machine learning is anyway and why how
we think about it at Google and why
we're so excited about it so to me first
of all when you think about machine
learning we're in the middle of this
massive hype cycle around it you
probably see graphics like these and
blog posts and news articles all the
time and you know they're they're just
generally talking about machine learning
we'll do this the machine learning will
do that and machine learning will change
the world and machine learning will take
away our jobs and you know there's
generally a lot of hype around this and
there's a lot of just hyperbole going on
around machine learning so what I wanted
to do is like level said a little bit
and say well here's why this is going on
so first of all this chart is the
typical hype cycle around a new
technology now it starts with a
technology trigger and that technology
trigger then will lead to something that
we call the peak of inflated
expectations and it's because of that
peak of inflated expectations that we're
getting
all those kind of news stories that you
know that I mentioned in the previous
slide after we passed through the peak
of expectations we tend to fall into
something called the trough of
disillusionment after which
enlightenment will come and then
productivity so as an example of this
remember back in 2007 when Steve Jobs
came on stage and he said one more thing
and he introduced the iPhone what
happened after that
was the peak of inflated expectations
the iPhone the cell phone was going to
do away with everything we wouldn't need
desktop computers anymore we wouldn't
need laptop computers anymore all we
would need is one of these devices in
our pocket who would do everything you
know and while those devices were
revolutionary and we all have
smartphones or most of us have
smartphones now they didn't replace the
desktop they didn't replace the laptop
we went through that peak of inflated
expectations and then once the trough of
disillusionment hit when people realized
okay this is what I can do with a
smartphone smartphone has a small screen
the smartphone is touched first it has
limited battery life
there were various things that I have to
still be able to do on a desktop that I
can't do in a smartphone then
productivity said in a new business this
came out of that things like uber right
can you imagine trying to call an uber
on your laptop it just it just wouldn't
work so when that trough of
disillusionment was hit and people then
began to be enlightened about what it is
that you can do with the smartphone then
productivity hit it so when it comes to
machine learning when it comes to AI I
think we're right about here right now
we're still heading towards the peak of
inflated expectations and I like to joke
that my job as an AI advocate it's the
tunnel you through that peak and get you
straight to disillusionment so I'm here
today as a professional disillusion or
so please forgive me if I'm if I'm a
downer with that but so let me talk
about one particular example think about
something like activity detection now
I'm curious sometimes it next we have a
lot of coders sometimes we have a lot of
people who aren't coders out of
curiosity - how many of you are actual
coders here just by show of hands oh wow
almost all of you okay cool
so think about something like activity
detection if you're writing code like
say take for example I want to say I
have a sensor that's giving me the speed
which are moving so I can say you know
what if my speed is less than 4 miles an
hour I can set my status as walking in
code like this but now I want to add
biking to that
sorry running to that so now it's like
okay if my speed is less than four then
I'm walking otherwise I'm running and
now I'll say I want to add biking to
that so if my speed is less than four
I'm walking if it's less than twelve I'm
running otherwise I'm biking it's a
basic algorithm and it kind of works but
then my boss who loves golf wants me to
add golf to it all I can say is oh crap
you know how do I write an algorithm for
that like when I hit a golf ball it goes
about three yards so I walk this far but
when Abraham hits a golf ball he will
hit it what 200 yards 200 you know so
it's like that the algorithm for him
will be a lot different from me and you
know we end up not being able to write a
reliable activity detection I know this
is a very naive algorithm based on speed
but hopefully it gets the point across
so how do we solve something like this
well that's the idea
that behind machine learning and how we
like to think of machine learning at
Google so first of all if we talk about
traditional programming traditional
programming is you express rules in a
programming language maybe Java maybe
C++ maybe JavaScript whatever those
rules will act on data and then out of
that you'll get answers like I had
earlier on if speed is less than four
then I'm walking that's traditional
programming in as high level as I can
actually draw it so machine learning the
idea behind that is we flip the axes on
this chart and we end up saying well
what if we have a whole bunch of answers
and then we have data associated with
those answers and then we have a machine
actually learn the rules itself as
opposed to me as a program are trying to
express those rules then some of the
limited scenarios and some of the
difficulties in a scenario like activity
detection that I mentioned they could be
fixed by saying I can get a whole bunch
of people walking and I can say this is
what walking looks like I can get a
bunch of people running and say this is
what running looks like this is what
biking looks like and yes sort of this
is what golfing looks like so the idea
behind machine learning is if I get all
of that data then it's just really as
simple as I can have a computer start
sifting through this data and spot the
patterns that make a commonality for
walking spot the patterns that make a
commonality for running biking golfing
all that kind of stuff so the framework
that we've built around this is called
tensorflow and tense flows what I work
on whoops
slightly broken animation there you
didn't see that so if we going back to
this
diagram that I showed earlier on machine
learning we think about it as we're
feeding in the answers we're feeding in
the data we write some code in a
framework like tensorflow that matches
the answers to the data and then in
fares the rules out of that what that
will do is build what we call a model
and the model is effectively a neural
network it's a really badly named
technology between you and me because
it's got nothing to do with the brain
and sometimes it makes you think it's
it's a lot smarter than it is but if you
think of a neural network it's basically
a bunch of interconnected functions and
each of these interconnected functions
calculate a probability based on their
inputs and but what that will end up
giving us is a model and then at runtime
we're gonna pass data into the model and
it will give us an inference or a
prediction out of that so now again when
I was like thinking of my activity
detection I've trained it on a lot of
people saying what it looks like to walk
run biking golf
now I'm gonna pass it a bunch of data
and it will say I think this looks like
walking instead of me writing code this
inference is happening based on that
data and pattern matching so building
these models is what we call the
training phase so as we're creating a
model as we're passing it the data as
we're making a neural network to sift
through that data to come up with the
patterns that determine one thing over
another we call that training and then
at runtime we call that inference so the
idea now is like okay now I know kind of
what machine learning is all about what
do I do
where should I run my inference and
abraham is going to tell us all about
that so now here the question where
should I do my inference well we have
two options here we can do the inference
on the cloud or luckily on the device
why am i treating the cloud if you want
to integrate into an existing cloud
service or you may want to use large
complex models that wouldn't be able to
fit in a mobile device or you want to
use actually aggregate learning from a
wide variety of sources and using the
cloud you can actually minimize the
impact on mobile battery and support
less performant all their devices but
what about the case for on device with
own device you'll be able to keep the
data local
anyway avoid round-trip latency this is
particularly useful on real-time
applications where you want to process
multiple frames in a quick succession
and sometimes you want your app to work
even when it's disconnected and you want
to reach users without reliable or
affordable connectivity and this time
you will be able to actually on device
it's a much better inference type and
Lawrence will go through the options the
Google provide here thanks so again
thinking about your inference you've
built a model you want to run inference
on it and as Abraham said there's two
choices you can either run it in the
cloud or you can run it on device so
let's first look at if you're gonna be
running your inference in the cloud so
you're not deploying a model to the
device here's where you see all the
cloud based inference and stuff that
you've been seeing at this conference
today so cloud based inference from
Google you know there's three pillars
there's computer vision based stuff that
we call sites there's language based
stuff for translation in NLP and then
it's conversational based stuff so those
these are models that have been built by
Google and services that have been
provided by Google so if you're meeting
these three scenarios and you want to
run inference in the cloud on these
three scenarios it's available to you
now in addition to that the models that
we've built of course can be customized
so the customization of these models
come through the product called auto ml
so you see like auto ml vision allows
you to retrain Google's computer vision
model to recognize your needs for
example you're a manufacturer who makes
widgets and you want some kind of
computer vision solution that recognizes
widgets you could use auto ml to retrain
it based on your widgets or in language
for example if you want to do
translation so translation from language
to language with machine translation it
can be pretty good it's getting better
all the time but it's trained on a very
general set again you might be a
manufacturer building something that has
a specific language associated with it
maybe your widgets have you know
particular things associated with the
widgets themselves that don't translate
properly you could retrain the machine
translation models based on your
specific domain that's what Auto ml is
all about
so that's cloud based inference for
these three specific scenarios but then
we always get the question okay
it's great if its sights if it's if it's
language or if it's conversational but
what if I'm doing something that's
unique and something different for
example somebody asked me recently about
they wanted to do network configuration
and they've these massive networks and
right now all of the configuration on
these networks is done manually wouldn't
it be great if they could see traffic on
these networks and then use
software-defined networking to
automatically configure their networks
based on a learned behavior so that you
know there's a great example of a custom
ML model so the question then becomes
well if I have a custom ML model and I
want to host that in the cloud what do I
do
so typically there's three main ways
that you build models for machine
learning
number one is a pre trained model a
little bit like I just mentioned some of
the services that we have in the cloud
somebody's built a model for you those
services I showed earlier on our models
that Google has built for you but we're
not the only people who build models so
the idea is that there are a ton of pre
trained models out there that you just
might want to use and you might want to
deploy them to the cloud so we have a
service called tensorflow hub which is
on ta TF hub dev where the idea is that
that's a repository of pre trained
models that might break out of the
scenarios that we're hosting and allow
you to have a model that then you can
host in the cloud
the second scenarios retraining models
now earlier i mentioned the fact that
you can do those those three pillars and
my previous slide that you could retrain
those for your scenario but what if you
have a scenario where there's an
existing model and you want to retrain
that so for example there may be a
computer vision model that you want to
retrain but you don't want to host it
with Auto ml well that's also possible
you'll be able to take a model out of
something like tense flow hub and you'll
be able to retrain that and you'll be
able to host it yourself I'll talk about
hosting yourself in a moment and then of
course there's building from scratch you
know you want to start from nothing you
don't want to use anybody elses model
you have a scenario that is so
particular and so unique to you and
that's what tensorflow is all about so
tensorflow is your API that will allow
you to define neural networks and train
them so that you can build a model ok so
then you've built a model and you want
to host it in the cloud yourself but you
don't want to use Google Cloud maybe you
want to host it on your own premise
maybe you want to host it in another
cloud provider so we have something
called tensorflow extended
now the idea behind tents flow extended
is that end-to-end enterprise-e type for
building managing and running models but
the orange box that I've highlighted
here is a technology called tensor flow
serving and you could just use tensor
flow serving from tf-x
deploy tensor flow serving to your
server or to another cloud provider or
wherever you want to put it and then you
can serve models out of that so we want
to just try to be able to cover every
base that we can cover if you want to
run cloud based inference so there's
really three pillars number one you can
use a service from Google and either use
that directly or retrain it number two
you can build your own model and host it
on Google or number three you can build
your own model and host it anywhere you
like so those are the three main
scenarios that we're trying to hit so
Auto ml for the first tensorflow serving
on Google cloud for the second
tensorflow serving on your own server or
in another cloud provider for the third
and if you want to learn more about 10
to flow extended CFX
you can go to github.com slash
tensorflow slash t FX it is open sourced
and we have our website around it which
is tensorflow org slash t FX so next up
is on device inference now the idea is
that abraham mentioned you know your
choice where you're gonna run your
inference number one you can run it on
the cloud or number two there was a
bunch of scenarios where you may want to
run it on device maybe you don't want to
pass data up to a cloud to have it
infrared on you want to do everything
locally there's a great video out there
for example of a farms in Tanzania in
Africa who rely on a cassava plant for
their food and the problem with the
cassava plant is that when it gets
diseased you don't recognize the disease
until it's too late but they actually
trained a tensorflow based model that
runs on device that can actually spot
the disease in a plant before the human
eye can spot the disease and all they
have to do is hold their phone over at
point the camera at the leaf of this
plant and it's part of the disease with
99 plus percent accuracy and as a result
they can root that plant out before it
infects the rest of the crop now this is
on a farm in Tanzania where they don't
have broadband connectivity they don't
have 4G etc etc so everything has to run
on device so that's just a great example
of like you know there are scenarios
where you may want to run it on device
beyond just privacy and all that kind of
thing so when it comes to models on
device it's actually this
name three choices number one pre train
models in the example of the cassava
sorry
a pre train model is you can go to TF
hub you can download a pre train model
and you can just use that directly then
there's retrained models and in the
example of the cassava what they did was
they downloaded something called mobile
net and mobile net is a well-known model
that's optimized for mobile use it
recognizes a thousand classes but then
they retrain that based on leaves that
they were able to categorize this is the
diseased leaf this is a nun diseased
leaf and again using the same thing that
I mentioned with the activity detection
you know you can train it that this is
what it does easily looks like this is
what a nun diseased leaf looks like that
type of thing so they were able to
retrain and build a model out of that or
of course you can just build from
scratch you can create your own model
and off you go but when it comes to on
device there's one extra step that you
need to do and that's to convert your
model to optimize it to run on the
device what this does is it shrinks the
model it makes a battery not battery
safe but it makes it better for working
with battery those kind of things so
there's four steps in this first of all
you build your model by either using
your pre trained retraining or creating
a model from scratch and tensorflow then
you save it as what's called a saved
model so saved model is a file format
that we're standardizing on intense flow
too and the idea behind saved model is
when you use that file format it'll work
on enterprise-grade scenarios in the
cloud it'll work on mobile it'll work in
JavaScript and the browser that type of
thing to be able to get it to work on
mobile then there's a TF light converter
which shrinks that model freezes parts
of it and allows you to use it on
tensorflow light so you go through these
steps for model conversion so that you
can then execute your model on a mobile
device and when I say mobile device were
actually moving beyond just your iOS and
Android the same process we'll be able
to use to be used so that your model of
and work on embedded systems so we
recently released support for
microcontrollers some microcontrollers
and like embedded systems like roswell
iot type devices like raspberry pi so
let me give a quick demo of this if we
can switch to a demo machine and my
screensaver kicked in while I was
talking
Thanks alrighty
so I'm actually gonna run this on the
Android emulator so we can see running
on the Android emulator now is like this
is a little app that's running in
tensorflow light so it's an open source
app you can go and download this now if
you like and what this is doing is it's
grabbing frames from the webcam you know
it's emulating the webcam using the
front camera on my laptop and then it's
classifying those frames using mobile
net mobile net as I mentioned earlier on
is built to work with a thousand
different classes so what it's doing
frame by frame is it's taking the frame
from the webcam it's compressing that to
the size of the image that mobile Nate
wants to use it's passing it to
tensorflow light it's getting back a
thousand classifications it's picking
the top three and then rendering those
on the screen so for example if I hold
up a water bottle we can see it did say
water bottle yeah there we go it's hard
to get it right with the angle I usually
have a banana for this I forgot to bring
a banana for with me and we didn't have
a backup banana there we go what about a
hundred percents there that kind of
thing so if I then just move this up
sometimes I put my face in it and I
don't I don't know what I wants to say
but so we can see the inference time
here and now this is running on the
Android emulator I'm sorry if it's
really small but the inference time is
about 300 milliseconds on an Android
emulator if you run this on a device
particularly an Android device that has
a neural networks API installed the like
for example like a pixel if you want to
see it running on my pixel later I can
show you it it'll do the inference in
about 30 milliseconds it's super super
super fast so we've been building
tensorflow light with that in mind to
shrink the model to optimize it to make
it super fast for inference so you can
even do like near real-time inference
like this running on an emulator on my
laptop which i think is really cool so
that's the demo if we can switch back to
the slides so in summary for the choices
that you're facing you know we we
realize that this was a very confusing
thing so part of what I've been trying
to drive in Google is a bit of a
strategy around ok what do mobile
developers need for machine learning and
we it was driven off of a floater
like this one and I'm sorry if it's
really small but it's kind of part of
the intent that we understand that it's
very confusing but if we think about
this if we look at the left hand side of
this flow chart those are the options
that are available if you want to run
inference on the mobile and if you want
to copy this flow chart just drop me an
email I'm happy to send it to you
because I know it's pretty small to see
on here and if you own if you look at
the right-hand side of this flow chart
those are the options that are available
to cloud developers so the idea is like
if you want to run inference on mobile
device there are a number of scenarios
maybe you want to have it connected to
the cloud to do your inference maybe he
wants it disconnected from the cloud you
know those are the things on the left
side of the flowchart ditto on the right
side yeah if you want to use Google
services or if you want to host your own
models those kind of things but we also
have an offering that Abraham is going
to talk about that gives us both so the
idea is an Abraham probably it will be
best to explain it with MLK King
florists as Laura's described ml options
may look like a scary map at first look
because you'd like to provide tailored
solutions for each use case as a
developer you want to implement these
solutions together hence you can use the
amount kit as a single SDK a market is a
mobile Mobile SDK that brings Google's
machine learning expertise to Android
and iOS apps in a powerful but yet easy
to use package it comes the set of ready
to use api's will call them base api's
and they work for both own device and
cloud based inferences they support
common mobile use cases like image
labeling face detection text recognition
and barcode scanning to name a few
while there are all ml models under the
hood they are as easy to use as any
other API let's look at a typical
workflow of someone looking to implement
a machine learning model in an app so
first the ml expert or the scientist
gathers massages as mr. data brings or
creates a model trains jeans and a
Bellator model maybe they will have to
do this in a few loops and then the
DevOps will deploy the model
and finally the software developer will
actually do the prediction but a market
makes this very easier you simply pass
in the data to their market library and
it will give you the information you
need whether you are new to or
experienced with machine learning you
can implement a functionality in a few
lines of code and it includes both
Android and iOS libraries while the own
device API is processed data quickly and
will work even when there is no network
connection the cloud-based API has
leverage the power of Google cloud
platforms machine learning technology to
give a powerful higher accuracy results
let's look at a specific example as you
can see here we are building an app that
requires and identifying the teams and
content of an image you will be using
the image labeling API in the cart
you'll be seen two icons here on the
devices API is our free of charge and
are best suited for scenarios where you
need a low latency and you might not
have a network connection and you're ok
with a more coarse-grained answer on the
other hand the cloud API call calls come
in a free coder
but I paid beyond that they provide the
most accurate results and are powered by
the state of the art machine learning
take muscles running on the Google cloud
platform but if you do have some email
experience or would like to bring your
own custom models as Lauren's already
describes you can do that too and using
the Americas with that you'll be able to
run your tensorflow Lite models on the
underlying framework whether it's
Android or iOS and you'll get further
benefits from a market since it's
integrated into the firebase such as
analytics remote config and a be testing
maybe that everyone is familiar with
firebase so firebase is Google's mobile
development platform which has tools for
building better apps
improving F koala
and further growing your business so
he's using a market with firebase will
actually allow you to upload your TF
light models into the firebase console
and dynamically deploy them to your
users this means that the apk bundle
size can be really kept small since you
won't be actually putting their model
inside the apk and you can do frequent
rollouts without having to republish
your app and you can defer the run a B
experiments firebase features such as
a/b testing remote config analytics make
this process really easy and I would
like to actually walk through a demo and
show all these features for you Cammy
thanks are so let's start with the base
ap ice this is small sample actually I
was doing using only the base ap ice
here
let's do some detection as I already
described on image labeling let's start
with that when I start using their own
device API ice they are really fast and
I get some answers here like beach rock
sky cliff and they're pretty good but if
I want like even find the results and
they better accuracy then I can use the
cloud here I made sure detecting from
the cloud as you can see now I get like
a more final great answers such as body
of water sky whale sure that weren't
actually in the normal on device API
call and we already described some use
cases there may be like some use cases
were on device ApS were better or the
the cloud API server better and in such
a use case let's say we are doing the
face detection we will need to use on
device API scope you want actually
process those friends really faster I
think you look right in lipstick by the
way I'm not sure so it's a small face
detection and we get the contours and we
are using the on device API here so that
we can actually process these frames
without having to go back to network and
waiting for the network response
but if we said like a market we were
able to like use even hybrid solutions
cause you are using a single SDK there's
another demo I did earlier let's see how
it works
but this is actually the results coming
on the top are coming from the one
device API cuz I won't actually get this
frames as quickly as possible I do use
my Mac for making music so saying
alright I'll instrument about that so
what I could trigger it it start with
the musical instrument days you see that
was the own device API but at the same
time I did a call to the cloud API and I
was able to strap the label with a
laptop and a better answer cuz I was
actually getting the laptop from the
cloud API I can do like few other things
as for some reason I'm getting 4,000
yeah there we go
if you see like it takes your change
from like the musical instrument tag I
hope not everything is a potential
musical instrument when you think about
it so you know this is sitting arm and
on top of that we also mentioned about
the custom models so you can actually
bring your own model to market as well
on the on the framework of TF lights so
I was actually using a local local model
here and doing the image labeling with
my mobile net or model and also I can
use the firebase to download another
model from the remote and I can use this
time using the same image labeling from
my remote model this way I was able to
use another model that wasn't in the apk
or in the bundle before but not only
that we can actually further use
firebase to go one level higher this is
my firebase console if you are not
familiar with it that are they actually
using as a console for my mobile
development here in the Americas section
I have some custom models
in these models I see like image
classification in magma or some others
that I already published so they can be
downloaded on the fly from my client
let's say I want to do some a B
experiment I want to see if I have a
better model if it's really better or
worse or have all my users actually will
react to this new model we can actually
run an a/b testing an a/b testing lets
me use some of these models or some of
these other parameters on the fly to my
app we'll use the remote config which
will actually my clients will be able to
get some conflicts on the fly again
let's say the ml experiment named as a
market just for the sake of example and
here I will be selecting my app for the
sake of example I'm just gonna say 5
percent of target users which I'll be
rolling my new model and I want to have
some goals so I can track some metrics
that if my new model is successful let's
say daily user engagement one of the
common goals the most use rozier so I
will be creating some parameters so I
can change these models on the fly let's
say ml model name and one of my models
is was image labeling and I can create a
new experiment now with a different
variant so the 5% of my users can
actually get the version 2 model with
that I will be starting an experiment
and I'll be a quick review here and from
now on I can actually start the
experiment and see how my users will
react through the experiment I can see
things that like that if there is a
better user engagement this model or
maybe my users are actually having their
lower churn rates or you find like
selling something from an in-app store
maybe they will be actually more getting
like more stuff codes actually they
really found what they were looking for
using the ml model can we go back to
slide
as I explained this was like I just
started this experiment so I won't have
the data ready but there was another one
actually I did experiment before here we
I can't see clearly with different
variants that one of the model actually
ended up having a lower user engagement
and the other model made my users
actually stay more maybe they really
found what they were looking in my app
using the nice new model
so using these experiments I can really
found the best model I can use and I can
even like process and get like better
models to go from there as lawrence
already described it google provides so
many different options either you are a
new or experienced email developer or
you want to do your inference on the
cloud or on the on the device and if you
want to bring your custom model or you
want to use the Google model and meet
America's we can actually use it on from
a single SDK and it's as easy as
sometimes like if you want to use the
base API is a few lines of code or you
can bring your own model as well and you
can further use firebase to get
analytics and to actually match your
different email models and see how they
perform
[Music]